if you enjoy content like this please
subscribe to the lucid programming
channel for more programming tutorials
in this video we're going to be going
over a very quick overview of both the
beautifulsoup
module and Python as well as the
requests module and Python as well so if
you're not familiar a very brief
introduction to both of those requests
is going to be a module that's going to
allow us to access various resources on
the web so allow us to obtain
information from various websites
navigate to those websites and
beautifulsoup is going to allow us to
parse that information so once we
navigate to those websites we might want
to extract certain types of content from
those websites and beautifulsoup is
going to allow us to do that so this is
going to be very much from the ground up
video the only thing I assume that you
have installed on your machine is Python
and pip P IP for installing Python
packages if you have both of those
things installed in your machine you
should be ready to follow along
one-to-one and it should work out just
fine so we're gonna go over some of the
basics of both the requests and
beautifulsoup
module in the first part of this video
and then we're gonna bring all of those
things that we learned into a very real
project or a very simple project I
should say this is really meant to be a
very minimal introduction to both of
these modules and just to see an example
of how you can be effective with both of
these things so let's just get started
by installing both the requests and
beautifulsoup modules on your machine
you probably will already have requests
installed but we'll just make sure that
you have that installed in any case so
go ahead and open up a terminal or if
you're on Windows command prompt and go
ahead and type in the following two
lines so pip install requests if you
already have this installed on your
machine like I do you'll see some
requirement already satisfied messages
pop up here that's totally fine if you
don't it will install on your machine
you probably should have this installed
already the other one is install
beautiful super 4 so go ahead and say
pip install bs 4 and I already have this
installed on my machine so we're good to
go
alright so we've got all the things that
we need installed I'm just going to go
ahead and close that window and we're
going to move back to our file here so
we've gone ahead and done this part
we've installed both of these modules so
what we're gonna do next is we're going
to import them and use them so we're
gonna import requests and
we're going to import a specific class
for the bs4 module that we installed
specifically the beautifulsoup class so
this is going to allow us to in the
terms of beautify content that we obtain
from a website and again that will make
it possible so we can extract
information from that content okay so
the first thing that we're gonna do is
we're going to use the request module
and I guess before I should go for
before I go any further I want to
mention that all of the code along with
the comments that is kind of supplements
in what I'm saying here all that is
going to be provided on my github and
the link to that will be accessible in
the description so you can go ahead and
download that if you want some
additional information as to what I'm
doing you're saying right so back to
this we're going to create a variable
called results and we're going to say
request dot git and then we're going to
pass in the website that we that we want
to access so in this case I'm just
accessing the home page of Google so I'm
just going to move my browser over here
so I'm just going to access this page
right there so I'm just going to go
ahead and get that and then what we're
going to do to make sure that the page
was actually accessed is we're going to
print out the status code which is just
an HTTP status code letting us know
whether or not the page was accessible
or not so for or for errors are an HTTP
code that's letting you know that the
content they looking for is not present
a 200 code is letting you know that the
content that you're looking for is
present and the responses okay so I'm
gonna go ahead and write this I'm going
to run it so we're gonna say Python this
file is called beautifulsoup
and requests that pi if I run this it's
going to run it let me just clear the
terminal because it's kind of messy let
me run that again and we see that the
the code that we get back from the
Google comm home page is 200 which
indicates that indeed the page is
accessible so another thing that we can
do is we can also print out some other
information of the web page that we just
accessed
like the HTTP headers and again for more
information on both the headers and the
status codes you can navigate to these
links that are in the comments that
point to the Wikipedia articles on both
of those topics so I'm just gonna go
ahead and write this and we'll see what
the headers look like so those are some
extra information on the Google comm
home page so for it so we can see here
the domain is Google com some other
information here as well that might be
of use I'm just going to go ahead and
close that it's more or less just to
verify that not only is the
age valid but it's also indeed the page
that we wanted to obtain let's keep
moving down here so the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to extract
the content of the page and that is
actually the source of the page and
we're going to store that in a variable
so the the object that we created here
this result the result has these built
in methods status code headers that's
how we were able to print out both of
those types of information that we just
printed out there another one that it
has is dot content and that is going to
return the source of that page and then
what we're going to do is store that
into a variable called SRC for source
and then we're going to have this
variable so let's go ahead and run that
and I'm just going to print out the
source so you can actually see what it
looks like I'm gonna run that like this
so we see a bunch of output here and
this is really just the web source of
the Google com home page so I'm just
going to go ahead and delete that now
it's kind of a lot of stuff all just
thrown on the screen that's great that
we can actually access it now we turn to
beautifulsoup because this is going to
allow us to actually do something with
that content so what we're gonna do now
that we've obtained that content we've
navigated to that web page we've
verified that we're on the actual web
page that we want and now what we're
gonna do is we're going to pass that
source variable into this beautiful soup
class creating a soup object and this
really is just kind of an object that
beautiful soup creates from this source
and it allows us to extract certain
types of information that we might want
to extract from this thing so we're
going to store the result of that object
in this variable called soup so I'm
passing in source here and there's an
extra parameter here this El XML you can
more or less just ignore this extra
parameter it doesn't really mean too
much if you don't have it in there
you'll get a warning essentially to tell
you to put it in there so it's there for
all intents and purposes but you don't
necessarily need to worry so much about
why this is here so we have the soup
object so for instance one thing that we
can do now that we have the soup object
is we can do things like give me all of
the links on the page so what we can do
is we create a variable which I can call
links and I can say soup dot final so
final is a method provided from this
beautiful soup object that we're
accessing here and what do I want to
find all of on this
I want to find all of the a tags so this
a is the argument that's being passed in
it tells beautifulsoup to say hey find
all of the a tags or all of the links of
this page and then store them in this
variable links and then we're going to
go ahead and actually just print those
out to the screen and just so we don't
get like too much content I'm gonna go
ahead and comment out the previous print
statements here just so we don't have
too much output on the screen
so we've got our links we'll print them
out and then we'll print a new line so
write that give it a run let's see what
we get so this is the output that we
just ran here and we can see that we
have a list so you can see the square
bracket here and the N square bracket
indicates a Python list and the contents
of this list are all of the a tags on
the page so if I move let's just take a
look at some of these links so we have
images we have one that has the text
maps so let me just kind of move this
back over here indeed you know if we
look let's just look at over here we
have this thing called images that is
pointing to the link in the top right
maps etc so we can look for other links
in this list that will correspond to the
actual links on the page that we have
just have searched for all the links on
the page so that's not so I'm going to
go ahead and comment that out so we
don't have excess output here and let's
just keep going down so get it all the
list of links is one thing but we might
want to actually extract certain types
of links so maybe the page that we're
requesting the page that we've just
simplified it has links that were
actually after so this example here says
okay actually I care about all of the
links that have a certain string in the
text field so what do I mean by the text
field if I bring this back up I
essentially want to look for all of the
links let's say that have the word about
in them so I want to see all the links
that have the word about so anything
that's an a tag where we between the a
and the slash a there's the word about
if it has that I want that link so
that's one example one use case out of
many that you could form in this in this
type of workspace so what we're going to
do is we're going to loop through all
the links that we've obtained from above
and then we're going to do is we're
going to say if the word about is in the
text of the link so again what
is amusing the dot text part of that
variable so as I'm looping through each
of these links in that list every one of
those elements in that list is actually
a beautiful soup element so that allows
me to call this dot text function on
each of those elements because that is
defined from this element that is
extracted it's stored in this list so
I'm saying look at the text in that link
in that list and is the word about in
that in that text if so then go ahead
and print out that link because I care
about that link and actually go ahead
and print out the print out the actual
thing that it goes to as well so that's
what this is doing here so link also has
a attribute or I should say if a
function attrs and I'm looking for a
specific attribute of that link so
inside the a tag there's an attribute
inside of that which is the href tag
inside of that and I'm saying give me
the content of that href inside of the
link tag which is the inside of this tag
that has the a so it's kind of a lot of
Russian doll kind of structure going on
there so let's go ahead and just print
that out I'll write that run it so we
have here is we have the link so we
found the about Google thing right here
so that's good and then we also have the
href attribute of this link so for
instance we see this hole this is the
hole a tag so we have everything from
the start of the a tag to the end of it
including the text including the href
and then what we did with the next line
is we said hey inside of the a tag
there's this attribute called href and
we want to access the content of that
attribute inside of the a tag and what
we did there that's precisely this and
that's what we're printing out right
here so I hope that makes sense I know
that's kind of drilling down quite a bit
and you can go pretty complicated with
these types of expressions but I think
once you understand this level you can
arbitrarily apply different levels of
complexity to your own situations your
own problems your own situations your
own scenarios so then already anyway so
we have this structure set up we have
kind of a general idea of how to use
both requests and beautifulsoup let's go
ahead and try to apply this
on a more elaborate webpage and the web
pages I have in mind is this web page
right here so this is just a collection
of briefings and statements given at the
White House so you can see the day of
this upload is September 12th and so
these are the most recent remarks by
briefings and statements that have
something to do with the White House so
there's a whole list of them and the
goal of what we're going to do with
beautiful super requests is we're going
to navigate to this page we're going to
try to find a way to extract all of the
links on this page and specifically all
of the links that have are sort of in
this feed here so that's what we're
going to do we're going to store them
into a list and then you could think
about doing whatever you like to that
list I mean of course like the
possibilities are are quite endless
depending on your goals but this just
kind of gives you the scaffolding the
structure the idea to take this and then
you know do whatever you want for your
own purposes so let me just minimize
this for now let's go back to this code
so right so what we're gonna do is I'm
going to open up a new tab so I'm going
to go ahead and say tab new I have
another file that I've created and have
some initial comments in which I've
called white house example not pi I'm
going to go ahead and open that file
here so you can see that I've just
opened a Python file which is called
white house example dot Pi and it just
has some comments which kind of indicate
what this is all about so we want to
obtain links from this website as we
just mentioned we want to well this is
just kind of telling you what this is
what this website is all about and the
goal as I mentioned before is to extract
all the links on that page and then just
kind of print them out into a list so
right so we could pretty much use the
majority of what we already have and we
can just kind of go from there
and more or less just copy and paste
some things that we have from a previous
file so let's start off by just doing
the very basic things let's go ahead and
import requests let's go ahead and say
from vs4 import beautifulsoup
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to let me just go back over to
this tab over here because I think it's
a little bit easier to just copy and
paste some of these things we're going
to want to do a very similar thing where
we use the request get method and
we're going to paste it not Google calm
this time but we're going to paste in
the website of the of these statements
so we're gonna go ahead and cut in there
I'm going to bring this website up I'm
going to copy this link here put this
back over there and then I'm just going
to go ahead and paste this in there so
this is now the website that we're
accessing these statements for the
content that we want to extract okay so
we've got that now the next step is we
want to let's go back over here so let's
see what else do we do so one of the
other things we did is we stored the
content once we've navigated to that
site is we stored the content of that
into a variable called SRC so that's
pretty much just a direct copy and paste
we can just move that right in there
so now we have a SRC variable that has
the content from the result and now what
we want to do going back over to the
initial file that we have I want to
create a soup object so I'm going to
copy that
move that over there that's also exactly
the same so I've got the source with my
page I've created a soup object based on
that source that will allow us to parse
and then let's go ahead and write some
new code so I'm going to create a list
which are call URLs this will just be
the list that will populate with the
links that we care about and then what I
want to do is I want to loop through all
the links so let's go back to the page
here so we have a couple links these are
the links right here on the page let's
just go ahead and inspect them so if
you're on Chrome or Firefox if you
right-click on an element on your page
there should be something like this
where it says inspect or inspect element
if we go ahead and click that we'll be
taken to this sort of thing over here
we're just showing us exactly what in
the source of this page this element
corresponds to you can see as I move
over this content various things are
being highlighted to indicate that these
things correspond to the code then I'm
sort of mousing over here it's a very
nice tool so basically one thing that we
can kind of observe is that all of these
links
if I right-click on this one as well all
of these links are contained in these h2
heading class tags so inside of the h2
tags we have the the a link or the link
that we're actually after so you can see
that all of the links on this page are
in fact formatted in this way so
all of these things are in between h2
tags and one thing that we can do we
didn't see this exactly but whether that
we can do is we can tell beautifulsoup
hey find all of the h2 tags on a given
page and then we'll loop through those
and then extract a link from those and
then we'll have our list that we're
after minimize that so we've got our
empty list so now let's do this let's
say for h2 tag in soup dot find
underscore all and then here remember if
we go back to this initial file here we
wanted to find all the links and what we
did is we said find all the things that
had the a tag well in this case we don't
want to find all the things with the a
tag just yet we want to find all the
things with with the h2 tag so we'll go
ahead and say find all of the ones in
this soup that have the tag h2 and then
inside of that if you recall if we go
back to that page inside of that h2 tag
there's an a tag and that's what we want
to extract so we'll go ahead and
minimize this and say okay now that
we're looping through all the h2 tags
let's say a tag is equal to h2 tag dot
find and what do we want to find we want
to find the a tag inside of that so
there's fine - all and there's fine
so find all is going to be a function
that's going to return to us a list it's
going to return all the ones on the page
there might be no items of this form of
the page there might be one there might
be many in any case it's going to return
to us a list this a tag is going to just
find a single element so it's just going
to find a tag the first tag that
corresponds to this and then we're going
to store that in this variable a tag
here now what we want to do we have
hypothetically our a tag and we're going
to add that to our urls list that we
have up here so we're gonna say URLs dot
append and then we're going to say a a
tag and actually I don't want to just
add the a tag I actually wanted to do
kind of similar to what we did over here
where I said not just the link but I
want the attribute of that link that
corresponds to href so going back to
this state here we've looped through all
of the h2 tags on the page inside of the
loop we have this thing that says okay
inside that h2 tag there should be
a tag and actually furthermore I want
the href attribute I want the actual
link that is inside of this href
attribute so let's go ahead and do
something very similar so let's say a
tag dots attrs and then we'll do href
just like we did before okay so that is
pretty much all we need there and then
just to make sure that we actually have
a list that's populated properly let's
go ahead and print out URLs let's see
what we have so we'll write this clear
the terminal and then we'll say Python
and the file is called a white house
example pi if we do that it'll run there
and grab a we can see that we have this
now this list of all of these links that
correspond to each one of the elements
of this page so we've successfully
extracted the links for each of these
briefings and statements pretty cool and
not very much code either you can see
this is quite concise
we're gonna be going over how to create
certain objects and beautifulsoup and
we're going to be taking a look at how
to make use of those objects to extract
content from web resources that you
might be interested in extracting the
content from so the first thing we're
gonna do is we're going to go ahead and
just import beautifulsoup so again
assuming that you have this installed
we're just gonna say from bs4 import
beautifulsoup which is the class that
we're going to use to simplify the HTML
content that we're going to eventually
parse in this video and the HTML content
that we're going to parse in this video
is actually just going to be described
by this variable here which is a string
that really just contains a very very
simple HTML web page so the reason that
we're doing like this is for one to keep
things very simple we just want to
illustrate very basic concepts about how
to kind of parse this type of content
the other thing is to keep it
reproducible we could see this example
on an actual website that's on the
internet somewhere however if the source
code for that website is changed in any
way then the video may become incorrect
as a result because the source change
and therefore our source might not be
doing the correct thing and at the time
whenever you happen to be watching this
could be giving you a different result
than what you actually expect so this
string is just going to describe a very
simple HTML web page then we're going to
use as our example and just to give you
a sense of what this looks like we're
going to just going to go ahead and
write this content to a file so what I'm
doing here is I'm just creating a file
called index.html and then I'm writing
that content that we defined up above so
the HTML doc string I'm just going to go
ahead and write that out to a file and
then if we go ahead and run this I'll go
ahead and clear the terminal so I'm
gonna go ahead and run this file which
is called beautifulsoup
objects we don't see in the output
because there's no output to be seen but
if we go to our directory in which the
file lives we can see that it did create
this index.html web page so we can go
ahead and open this up in a browser and
if we do so we see this is the HTML
rendering of the string that we saved
and wrote to file so you can see there's
some very simple content on this page
there's some stuff between some bold
tags stuff between some paragraph tags
links things like that so we're gonna
see how to make use of beautifulsoup
objects to extract content like this and
my
is that you can see it applied in this
very somewhat contrived in simple
setting and optimistically apply it to
your own setting in which you want to
apply these types of ideas so I'm just
going to close this I'm going to
minimize this and we're going to go back
to our code so let's keep moving on down
here so the next thing that we're going
to do is we're going to create a soup
object based on the HTML doc string
variable that we defined up above and so
this is going to allow us to parse the
HTML content so one thing that I do want
to mention that I don't believe I did
mention in the QuickStart guide is one
thing that's kind of neat is you can use
this prettify function which is provided
from the beautifulsoup class which
allows you to output the HTML code in
sort of a nicely formatted way so I'm
just gonna go ahead and write this and
give this a run so if we give this a run
we see that the HTML code is printed out
very nicely it's indented properly and
it just kind of looks very clean and how
you would expect it to be properly
formatted let's say if you're writing
this code so alternatively if we get rid
of this prettify function if we just
kind of remove that there write it and
then run it again you can see that this
output here that we got kind of
scrunches everything together so it
really depends on what you're looking
for what you're trying to go for if
you're getting like a big sense of maybe
a more complicated web page it might be
nice to look at this form here otherwise
if you kind of want to see everything
scrunched on just this screen here it
might be fine to look at it like this so
it really depends on what you're going
for but it's nice to know that this type
of function exists so I'm just going to
comment this out so we don't have a
whole ton of output as we're moving
along here in this file and the next
thing that we're going to cover here are
tags so what we're going to do is we're
going to take a look at this code this
HTML source and the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to print out
the bold tag so if we do soup dot B this
is going to give us the first occurrence
of the bold tag in the HTML that we're
parsing or from the soup so if I go
ahead and write this and give this a run
we should the output here is this
content here so it's sum the dorm loss
the story between these bull tags so I
just want to also point out that this
content this HTML content is really just
ripped straight from the beautiful soup
documentation page with some minor
alterations so that bold tag that we
just extracted is this one right here it
goes it starts from the top of the file
it keeps moving down and finds the first
thing that has bold tags and says ok I'm
going to print this out alternatively if
we said soup B but P this would also do
the same thing but with the P tag so
here we have class title the Dormouse a
story indeed if we go up to the top of
this HTML source start from here keep
going down it's the same thing here this
is the first occurrence of a P tag in
the file so that's what's going to be
printed out there so I'm just going to
comment that out and maybe we don't want
to just print out the first occurrence
but maybe we also want to do something
similar so we're going to kind of build
up to a way that we can find all of the
tags of a given element so another thing
that we can do that's very similar to
what we just did instead of soup dot B
or soup dot dot P we could do similar
thing where we use the find function so
if we say soup dot find and then give it
the tag that we're looking for this will
give us again the first occurrence in
the HTML documentation sorry in the HTML
dock that has a bold tag so if we go
ahead and write this and I'm just going
to clear the terminal so we don't have
too much output we see that this is also
the first occurrence of the bold tag
that we got from before what we just did
souped up B so I'm just going to go
ahead and go back here comment that out
now maybe what we want to do is we want
to find all of the occurrences of the
bold tag in the HTML document that we
are parsing so I'm going to go ahead and
uncomment this and the function that
we're going to be making use of here is
fine to underscore all so this is a
built-in function that we can use on a
soup object that is going to find all of
the content in this soup that pertains
to this bowl tag so I'm going to go
ahead and write this and run it and
we'll see that this returns a list where
each of the elements in this list our
beautiful soup objects that correspond
to everything that contains a bold tag
so that's also good to know so let's
keep moving down in this file so another
thing that we can also think about is
something called a name so if we did
soup dot B dot name this is going to
give us the name of the tag so for
instance let's take a look at the first
occurrence of the bold tag like we did
before and then we'll tag on a dot
so if we write this and give it a run we
see that the name of the tag is B so
that's essentially what this is going to
give us it's telling us the name of the
tag that we've just printed out
alternatively we can alter the name and
have that reflected in the source so for
instance if we wanted to for whatever
reason alter the name of this tag we
could do so in the following way so we
can define a variable tag which is equal
to soup dot B so this is the first
occurrence of a bold item in the HTML
document that we're parsing we can print
that out just to see what that is so I'm
going to comment this out so we don't
get too much output so we've created
just a refresh we created a variable
called tag which is equal to souped-up
be the first and bold occurrence in the
HTML document we're gonna print that out
we're gonna see what that corresponds to
which is something we've already seen
before and then what we're going to do
is we're going to say tag name which is
a property just like we did we printed
that out here so we're gonna say tag
down name instead of it being equal to
bold or B we're gonna say actually set
that name equal to block quote so it's
just some other thing we could set it
equal to whatever we want I'm just using
block quote as an example and then what
we can do is we could print out the
resulting tag so what we've done is
we've found the tag which is the first
bold one printed that out to verify what
that was and we've actually altered this
is a mutable object we're actually
altering the bold content of this tag
into a block quote and if we go ahead
and print that out we'll see that this
is no longer between B but it's between
a block quote you can see it starts and
finishes with this tag a block boat now
so I'm just going to comment that out
there and let's keep moving on so let's
go on to attributes so let's go ahead
and say that we want to define a given
tag just like kind of how we did before
here where we're finding the in this
case this the third element of the list
that is returned for all of the bold
objects that we're looking for in the
HTML document so if we go ahead and go
back up to our source remember that one
actually let me not even go up that high
but if we went back to this function
here where we found all of the bold tags
remember that returned to us a list of
all of the beautiful soup objects that
corresponded to a bold tag in our HTML
document
so what I'm essentially doing here is
I'm saying find all of those elements
and just give me the element index - of
that list and then let's just print that
out just see what we got
so we'll go ahead and do that so in this
case it's a bold tag that has ID is
equal to 1 and then in between that is
this is this named test1 and then it's
the end of the bold tag so let's go
ahead and and work with this and see
what we can do so this specific tag as
we saw has an attribute so it's a bold
tag but it has an attribute inside of it
which is called ID so we can actually
access that attribute by saying tag and
then using the array index notation so
it's overloaded that if we can access
the ID field of this by saying tag open
square bracket ID close square bracket
which is the name of the attribute that
we want to access if we go ahead and
write that we can see that the value of
the ID field that we just access is
equal to want and it's what's being
printed out there so it's kind of cool
so we can move right along and see sort
of another example of this thing let me
just comment these lines out so we don't
get too much output I'll go ahead and
clear the terminal as well so now let's
go ahead and consider another tag for
the sake of example so I'm also creating
another variable here which I'm calling
tag and now I'm just going to print that
out to see what we have so this is the
index 3 element of the list that is
returned from all of the bold tags on
our page I'm just going to go ahead and
write this and run it so now this time
we have another bold tag which has not
just one attribute so before we had one
that was just one attribute which was ID
now we have some other attribute which
is called another attribute which is
also something else so notice that this
ID is pretty widely used in HTML you'll
see like a lot of different elements
will have ID is equal to something and
this another attribute is not typically
used it could be anything else in the
whole world what we're gonna see here is
a way that we can extract not just one
attribute but also this attribute as
well so if we kind of move right along
here we can say print out tag ID just
like we did before we're printing
the attribute of the tag that we've
defined up here that has the field ID
and we can also do the same thing for
another attribute which is the name of
the other attribute that we're trying to
access so if we write this and then run
it you'll notice that it was able to
successfully do it for ID so the ID was
equal to variable that's printed out
here and then another attribute we
printed that out as well and that's
equal to one and just like how we had
here where this is mutable we were able
to alter the name we can also do the
same thing for these sorts of tags as
well we'll see that a little bit so let
me just comment these lines out here
let's create another tag variable so
I'll just set it equal to the same tag
variable that we had before just to
verify that let's print that out so this
is the same tag so I'm just setting a
variable tag equal to that and then I'm
just printing that out so if we wanted
to see one or all of the other
attributes that this tag actually has so
we knew because we looked at it it had
an attribute ID and had another
attribute called another attribute but
what if we didn't know what those wore
what if we just wanted to see all of the
attributes this particular tag had so
beautiful su provides to us something
called in this method here attrs which
is going to allow us to see all of the
attributes of a given tag so if we go
ahead write this and print it out we see
that it returns a dictionary where the
key is the name of the attribute and
then the value is the value of the of
the attribute so the key here another
attribute this is equal to 1 that's the
value of this entry in the dictionary
and likewise this key here for ID the
value of this is equal to very bold so
it's kind of neat as well so let me just
go ahead and comment I will keep that
actually I'll just print get rid of
these print statements so as I mentioned
before these sorts of things are also
mutable so we can change the attributes
the values of the attributes to some
other value if we wish so just to kind
of refresh we have this variable tag
which is equal to the element that we
saw before so let me just write that and
run it so this variable tag is equal to
this
soup object here and what we can do is
we can say okay let's access the element
another attribute and recall that that
value was equal to one what we're doing
here is we're saying it actually set
that value equal to something else so in
this case I'm just setting it equal to
two so let's go ahead and print out the
result of that mutable action so we'll
notice that the first time before we
make any alterations the attribute value
is 1 however once we change another
attribute once we change that value
equal to 2 notice that it's reflected
here so we're able to actually change
the values of those things which is kind
of neat so I'm just going to go ahead
and now comment this out and I'll
comment out these print statements as
well so let's keep moving on actually
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to keep
this tag that we had before and
illustrate one further points about this
tag so another thing that we we can do
since these things are mutable is we can
also eliminate or delete the fields of
an attribute so just like we do for a
Python list when we're trying to remove
an element from a list we can use the de
el keyword in Python to remove that
element from the list and this is what
we're doing here we're saying ok
the tag that had those two attributes ID
and another attribute actually just go
ahead and remove ID so let's go ahead
and print out let's print out the tag
before so just to kind of give a sense
of where we're starting from we're
starting from this thing here and then
what I did is I said de el ID and notice
that after I did that and then printed
out the resulting tag there's no longer
an ID field in this thing so we can also
do the same thing for the other field if
we so wish and then prints out the
result of that and notice that we have
again what we're starting with this
beautiful soup object with both of these
fields and that we've deleted both
another attribute and ID from it we've
printed out the result so just kind of
showcasing what you can do with this so
I'm just going to go ahead and comment
all of those out now and let's also
comment out this tag as well let's keep
moving on down and see what else we can
do so we're gonna look at some strings
so we're going to define a variable tag
which is the same
think that we've been working with for
the past couple of examples just to kind
of showcase that we're just going to
print that out to the screen so this is
the tag variable that we're working with
now same thing that we've been working
with again for the past couple examples
and then what we can do is beautiful
soup also provides to us a dot string
method and if we print that out let's go
ahead and see what we get we print that
out we get the content that's between
the tags so notice that this is what
beautiful soup is considering as the
string the elements between the angle
brackets between the tags themselves so
this is the string content that we're
printing out here and that's what this
is giving to us so let's just keep
moving down here so I think we're pretty
much at the end of the file I'm just
going to get rid of these two print
statements another thing that we can do
is just like we saw before the
mutability of these things we can also
alter the string content in between
these tags as well so if I do something
like tag dot string and then replace
with so this is just a function that is
going to allow us to replace the content
that is that string with something else
and I'm replacing the content with this
is another string and then if we print
out the result of that we'll see we'll
see what we get so let me just kind of
review what I'm doing here creating the
variable tag that we've seen before I'm
printing out the original tag with no
alterations whatsoever then I'm using
this dot replace width method to
actually alter the text inside of that
beautiful super object and I'm going to
print out the resulting tag so we should
see is we should see the original tag
with test2 in between and then after
we've replaced this content with this is
another string will see the same tag but
with the text altered so let me just go
ahead and write that and because we kind
of have a lot of output on the screen
let me just clear it and then let's go
ahead and run this so indeed this is
what we see we see the initial attribute
or the initial beautifulsoup object with
test2 unaltered and then we've replaced
that with the method given to us by
beautifulsoup and we've replaced it with
this text here this is another string so
that's just some of the attributes or
objects I should say a beautiful soup
and some of the things that you might
want to do when you're parsing a page
you might want to parse a page make
these changes and then write these
things to a file for very
reasons there's a lot of different
things that you can do I hope that this
kind of showcases the things that you
can do and hopefully it's broadly
applicable to sites that you may be
encountering in your own in your own
scenarios so if you have any questions
or comments don't hesitate to leave them
below I'll do my best to answer them so
thanks again for watching and I'll catch
you in the next video